but we pilots do you understand welcome
to pop CIPA crimp uprising where we're
on the set and gonna have the cast of
Pacific Rim uprising come out and train
these little Jaeger puppies to fight
these kaiju and save the city whoever
gets the most kind you wins but whatever
we're all winning
it's puppies
[Music]
you guys know these are kaiju and this
is my this is my teach the jaegers how
to attack the kaiju so that we can
protect the John yeah we got a plan here
okay
see the yellow Pikachu yeah over here
it's gonna make a diversion and then you
guys are gonna come in okay and just to
help you out we've actually translated
some iconic movie lines and to pop
friendly language just to give them a
little bit of inspiration
I would love to inspire them yeah just a
motivation okay guys listen up man this
is real serious business all right this
is the fate of the world all right as we
know it the only thing standing in front
of the dog apocalypse is us but doesn't
matter where you walked here from who
believed you were a good boy who didn't
there are dogs we remember as legends
but they didn't start out that way
they started out like pups
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference this is our chance to
run and pee on grass puffy violets do
you understand yes now you help me save
the wall but all of you you you and you
let's do this ready
it's good innovation to life what you
think see took one down he's gone - I
told you diversion happening I'm really
struggling with gypsy by the way this
puppy right here is ripping stuff that's
father like son would you say he's got
like a Clint Eastwood thing going up its
get a little scowl yeah you guys hit
treats in the cage what's this Jaeger in
the pits good yes I can't force this
puppy to be hero
[Music]
ah this is so sweet today we celebrate
our and this is a far stretch guys and
dog puffs dense day they may take our
labs but they'll never take our freedom
a mutt as he'll and I'm not gonna
terrier anymore I eat your milk phone I
eat it up oh I'm in tears today the edge
of our hope at the end of our leash we
have chosen not only to snuggle
ourselves but to snuggle each other
today there is not a man no woman's best
friend in here that shall roll our horse
it alone today we are canceling the
apocalypse yes we are
[Music]
[Applause]
they're all freaking out can you make a
kid to go see Pacific Rim surprising
yeah I mean this this film is the best
film of 2018 I said it the puppies that
we've cast in this are absolutely
incredible we've got the Oscar winning
puppy right here this film is the best
the best bet for anybody puppies and
humans alike
we taking all these kiya jus down
this is our time
this is our chance let's do this
situation kept rising and then let's if
Vikram uprising is this what you would
already see I gave my dog caffeine
they're not allowed so stoic doesn't
look like he's ready for battle my puppy
is specific to maintenance maybe he's
the commander maybe don't patronize us
do you have any final thoughts I know
Khalil take no more questions no more
questions at this time okay this is so
sweet by the way don't expect every
movie to be like these people is really
a doctor every movie then I'm motivating
for life I'm getting this puppy
Haley's actually should adopt one of the
puppies that was available today what
are you gonna name her I'm naming her
scrapper and I think we have a real bond
you are doing such a wonderful thing
thank you thank you for watching
pups if ax crimp uprising we hope you
enjoyed it as much as we did and
remember there are tons of animals that
need to be adopted so do support your
local shelter if you can huge huge
thanks to Shea's strays and the animal
wellness foundation and make sure to go
to see Pacific Rim uprising on March
23rd
[Music]